hello there
i'm premium cables john oliver although
uh if you don't read internet news sites
you probably know me as
oh he has a show now really okay okay
but if you're a regular huffington post
reader you may recognize me as the man
who tore apart
fifa verbally pantsed dr oz
and pulverized fictional canadian
caillou's stupid bald head into dust
now to be fair they didn't say that last
one but i did do it and i'll do it again
for say caillou at least get a
hobby you cheap charlie brown knock
off okay that feels good
um but right now uh i'm going to widen
my swathe of destruction or to put it in
terms the internet will respond to
what happens at the two-minute mark of
this video will amaze you
because the internet does not know how
to describe
things anymore and tonight i'm going to
take on pinatas
or as they should be called the trojan
donkeys of diabetes
first of all first of all and this is
important
pinatas they teach children that animal
cruelty is delicious
which which yes often it is but we're
not here to talk about factory farming
if you're going to give me candy just
give me the candy okay
don't make me go or joe pesci on a
papier-mache spongebob
okay spongebob doesn't owe me money he
didn't disrespect my family
but for some reason we're trickle
treating execution style at my nephew's
birthday party
now at this point you're probably
thinking hey john stop
you have demolished slammed eviscerated
decimated and teabagged pinatas
but you would be wrong because that's
not what any of those words mean
up until this point i've just made some
deservedly mean jokes
about them but now for the sake
of accurate internet headlines
i will literally destroy them i will
destroy them okay
okay you want to see me literally
destroy pinatas
you'll get it
did that look as cool as it felt
thank you all for joining me for this
epic pinata takedown
we will be back on hbo sunday september
the 7th with a new episode
of last week tonight 30 minutes of news
that will change
how loosely you are willing to define
the word news we'll be back
thank you